many of us remember thanks for exams
because we learned them without context
and to learn without context is what we
call rote learning so what if I told you
that you don't need to remember things
it is possible if we try to understand
the core concepts and to learn or to
understand we need to first start by
asking the right questions for example
instead of asking why are they no real
humans in don't memorize videos we could
ask who are the humans behind these
videos hey guys my name is Serena and
I'm the voice behind all the videos that
you see on this channel we have an army
of animators illustrators and educators
who helped us create them and it all
began with Ganesh and Rohan
hi I'm Ganesh hi I'm Rohan let me begin
by telling you why I started don't
memorize a few years ago I told my dad
that I want to be a teacher and I want
to teach hundreds of students over the
next five years to which he replied
hundreds isn't cool you know what's cool
millions and that's why I started this
YouTube channel and I decided to join
him in this journey because I strongly
believe in the company's goal to be the
best teachers out there we make videos
ranging from school level math and
science test prep content and you've
started adding some brain teaser videos
as well we believe that to learning not
just helps you know exams but in your
life too so we asked each other how
would we define real success if a
million students end up saying I've
become a better person because of don't
memorize that would mean real success
for us finally we'd like to thank all of
you for watching our videos giving us
your feedback and participating in our
contests if you feel there are others
who could benefit from our content don't
forget to share our videos with them and
as always do share your thoughts with us
in the comment section below we'd love
to hear from you to subscribe to our
Channel click on the atom you see your
and to watch an interesting video click
on the Newton squared is there